it's the discovery of a lifetime
physicists have spotted gravitational
waves churned up by two black holes
locked in a death spiral deep in space
no one has seen such waves before and
they're about to open new eyes on the
cosmos until now scientists have learned
about the universe mainly by studying
light and other electromagnetic waves
from space but gravitational waves are
ripples in space itself they are set off
by stellar cataclysms such as massive
neutron stars or black holes whirling
together to sense the waves physicists
use massive l-shaped optical devices
called interferometers each arm of the L
is four kilometers long there are two of
these devices in the United States and
together they make up LIGO to detect the
stretching of space LIGO uses laser
light to measure and compare the lengths
of the two arms when a gravitational
wave ripples past it will stretch the
arms by different amounts causing the
light to warble out of the
interferometer the measurements are
sensitive to within one ten thousandth
of the width of a proton physicists hope
to use the waves to test Albert
Einstein's theory of gravity and also to
detect strange objects that until now
were completely invisible take the
signal that LIGO detected the black
holes responsible are three times as
massive as normal and nobody knows why
it's just the first surprise from what
promises to be a whole new type of
astronomy